starting pitcher for the diamondbacks
tonight madison bumgarder
who has completed seven innings in each
of his last three starts including last
sunday against these padres at petco
park you see his season numbers right
there that outstanding performance
against the padres last time out seven
innings threw only 80 pitches in that
ball game was extremely efficient
against the padres graham's having a
good year for the padres he's really
solidified that top spot of the batting
order he swings here and hits one to the
second baseman that's rojas and he fires
the first for the out
i guess my point is uh sometimes when a
power pitcher loses his power he loses
his occupation
rojas gonna have to charge and hurry up
nicely done two ground ball outs two
four three put outs for rojas
this might stay playable for christian
walker
christian has got it
how about that start from madison
bumgarner before the padres is blake
snell last time out against the same
diamondbacks seven innings strong two
hits no runs
struck out 13 28 year old making his
20-second start
there he is with a 2-2 pitch to marta
breaking ball hit on the ground to third
could be two the second for one on to
first it is two
[Applause]
and that is strike three that's a good
first for blake snell picks up his first
k of the night
there's the curveball he gets his first
strikeout
[Applause]
high fly ball to right
and peyman smith's got a beat on it
baby makes a catch nola back to first
andre's threatening against madison
bumgarner meyers on first nola on second
two outs for trent grisham who's hit in
four straight and eight of his last 10.
[Applause]
coming up here to smith
nice and that's on the outside corner
for strike three
second strikeout for blake snell two
down in the second inning and it is
taken for strike three that was a nasty
little curve ball and three k's now for
blake all three have been looking
so now it's up to
ross to try and get kelly home
reaches down and pokes it into left
center this will get carson home
rojas into third and it's one nothing
diamondbacks
that is strike three gets him looking to
end the inning fourth strikeout for
snell but the diamondbacks take a
one-nothing lead
1-1 pitch to snell
and a ground ball down to first walker
charges gets an easy op steps in the bag
and a quick right to the dugout for
blake snow one out here in the third
inning ham strikes out swinging
i guess you can call that a swing it was
kind of a wave or a half swing
here's the curveball carson kelly
completes the strikeout that's number
three for mad bum who holds a
one-nothing lead
[Applause]
three-two curveball swung on and missed
strike three
five strikeouts now for snell one out in
the bottom of the third inning
line to center
and incoming diving is grisham to make
the catch
nice grab by grisham
diving forward to make the backhanded
snag carson singled and scored to lead
off the second came home and a two-out
rb guy knocked by dalton version
nell trying to come in with that heater
a great at bat right there by carson
kelly and that gives baby smith a chance
now with two on and two out
on the ground to short and crude worth
to second base for the out and snell
it's out of any further trouble it's one
nothing diamondbacks at the end of three
2-2 pitch
line to right field and it's going to be
over the head of smith and off the wall
meyer's got to hurry as he's headed to
second base and the throw is going to be
laid a double for will myers
ground ball down the first baseline it's
a fair ball and tagging the bag
is walker as myers takes third base
drops this one to third cabrera makes
absolutely certain myers isn't going
anywhere
1-1 defam and a ground ball chop to
short ahmed's got it and the throw to
first and he got him and a nice job by
bob garner as he gets out of trouble the
lead off double that man is stranded at
third base
to centerfield and grisham
for out number one in the bottom of the
fifth inning
martin is over two tonight and is over
the series thus far
fly ball left field
it's gone
that's his first home run since june the
second then it's two nothing
diamondbacks or waited on that curveball
nicely that time
big looping curve ends up right in the
middle of the strike zone martay knows
it right away came off the bat at
113 miles an hour
driven to left and fam goes back to make
the catch on another line drive
home run on a line drive by cattell
martay has put the diamondbacks on top
two nothing
[Applause]
they fly to right right at pavon smith
for round number one
this is slicing the left center
can't tell marta is there right in front
of our show
two outs in the sixth
there's a drive to right but right at
smith for the owl the ending's over the
faces are loaded with one out from
madison bumgarner who struck out
twice against blake snell
strike three
nick will at least have a chance with
two outs and the bases load
[Music]
fly ball
shallow right back going frazier he's
under it and he makes the catch out of
the jam is johnson down here
no doubt about it two in one and hosmer
swings grounds it the other way off the
glove of the third baseman cabrera who
dove towards the line and into left
field for a base hit
and the padres will bring the tying run
to the plate with nobody out in the
seventh will myers coming up he's two
for two already with a single and a
double
high drive to left field back goes far
show at the wall this game is tied
two run home run for will myers just
13th of the year and it's 2-2
hosmer with the bloop elgayo with the
blast first pitch breaking ball
and he crushed it will myers going above
and beyond the left center field wall to
tie it up
3-2 to myers
popped it up should get him ross out
calling for it and makes the catch to
retire the side so the double wasted bar
show tonight
singled over run in the second and light
out hard to center in the fourth and
then intentionally walked in the six
dalton var show fly ball
right field diamondbacks walk it off
first career walk-off rbi and home run
for dalton varsho and the diamondbacks
have taken the first two games in this
four-game visit from san diego 3-2 they
win it that's a no-doubter off stamen
first guy he faces tonight dalton
varshall walks it off out to right field
and the celebration is on